thank you very much mr. chairman and
welcome dr. Allendorf and I and I
apologize for not being here earlier let
me I want to ask you mostly questions
about the financial crisis and then I
want to ask you another question about
how CBO makes their accounting
assessments question number one between
2001 and 2007 commercial banks alone not
investment houses just commercial banks
alone made some 700 billion dollars in
profit a lot of money now as a result of
the greed recklessness perhaps illegal
behavior on the part of a relatively of
Wall Street they are coming to the
taxpayers for huge bailouts and we have
no idea how much that's going to end up
costing very simple question the average
guy goes out and has a lot of lucky wins
the lottery makes a lot of money puts
the money in the bank bad times come
says well good good news I won the
lottery I have a lot of money I'll pay
off my debts these guys have made
unbelievable sums of money then through
their greed and recklessness they
created a terrible crisis and now we
have to bail them out where did all
their profits go as you know senator the
banks paid out profits in the form of
dividend payments to shareholders
you know they've paid salaries to
managers yep that money is not directly
recoverable legally but I certainly
understand the frustration that the
American people feel yeah at the
situation yeah they sure do in other
words some people became incredibly rich
and then when things got bad it's the
average Joe who has to bail them out
and and somehow or another we have to
deal with that and that is why by the
way in terms of the first bailout I
proposed I voted against it I proposed
the surtax on people whose families had
at least a million dollars in income
because they of people who benefited
from Bush's economic policies in general
our second question is taxpayers provide
all of these I guess what uncle capital
injections into these banks we're
talking three hundred and fifty billion
plus more in the next tranche and people
go to these bank
News reporters go and say tell us what
you're doing with this money and the
bank said oh well thank we thank the
public very much for bailing us out but
we don't want to tell you what we're
doing with the money
are you using this money to lend it out
to small businesses the great jobs none
of your business
we will do with it as we want to do with
it all right so my question to you is
why is there not why haven't we forced
transparency and and demanded that these
banks lend out the money as they were
supposed to do rather than perhaps and
use it for bonuses for mergers
acquisitions etc I think as an analytic
matter senator it's very difficult to
track what happens to a dollar that goes
into a very large and complicated
institution a lot of money goes in and a
lot of money goes out of these banks
knowing what was done with a particular
dollar is really I think an almost
unanswerable question there's also a
broader problem which is that we don't
know what would have happened otherwise
so he called must talk a lot about the
counterfactual situation right without
the money what would have happened but
don't you think if I give you you come
to me you say look you know I need a lot
of help and I'm saying okay I'm a nice
guy we're gonna bail you out don't I
have a right to have understanding what
you said you telling me well in general
this is what I'm doing we are I know you
wanted us to make loans that loosen up
capital don't you think we have a right
to know a little bit more than these
banks are telling us I think certainly
the government can set the conditions
that it wants on the unease and on these
injections and it did set some of course
as part of the legislation authorizing
the tarp there will in some cases be a
trade-off between the speed with which
actions can be taken and the care with
which they can they're taken and I think
one of the when the tarp was being
debated of course there was a great
sense of urgency I think in the minds of
most people watching the financial
system and that may be one reason why
more discussion was not made at that
time of these issues with the exception
of our friend friend Bernie Madoff who
pulled off the remarkable I mean again
incomprehensible how you could pull off
a fifty billion dollar Ponzi scheme in
this day and age without being too
detected by the SEC do you believe that
Wall Street leaders engaged in illegal
behavior and that some of them should
end up behind bars in the coming years I
I think it's a very appropriate to
prosecute people who broken laws I'm not
a lawyer
I don't really know securities laws so
I'm not a good judge of what's happened
I think where there was law breaking it
should be addressed luckily without
saying but you know people break the law
we generally try to prosecute them I
think there is an outrage on the part of
the people mr. chairman that is not
necessarily perceived here in Congress
the recklessness the greed I suspect the
illegal behavior of maybe a few hundred
few thousand people has impacted and
destroyed the lives of millions of
people in this country and in my view
they have got to be held accountable and
I am concerned that because they are
rich and powerful they don't get the
same treatment as the average criminal
but I think we have got to address that
issue senator if I could just interrupt
and it won't come out of your time just
on this issue I think you're I think
you're right I think we will find law
breaking I think we will find criminal
wrongdoing I think people should go to
jail I've written the Attorney General
and I've asked that in every one of
these cases where government funds are
infused that there be an investigation
and that people be held to account there
have got to be prosecutions of criminal
wrongdoing and it's breathtaking
I think we're gonna find a lot do you
know what the problem is with Jim is the
amount of money is so huge that nobody
can get the hands around it somebody
Rob's fifty thousand dollars thirty we
understand the problem what are we
talking about trillions of dollars what
is the trillion dollars nobody in
America understands without us so the
problem is so big that I think we have
not focused as the chairman said on on
potential illegal behavior and what
we're gonna do to these people all right
let me ask you another question
we've talked primarily about talk funds
but there's another huge source of
funding from the Fed which I think you
estimated to be about over two trillion
dollars two trillion dollars few bucks
here there heads up which is going out
to whom I mean I don't quite understand
how over two trillion dollars can be
lent out mr. chairman I'm not quite sure
that we know who is receiving this money
we don't know what the terms are how do
you lend out two trillion dollars of
federal funds through the Fed and nobody
knows anything about this [ __ ] don't
know well the way you do it is that you
try to save a financial system in which
that consists of tens of trillions of
dollars hundreds of trillions of dollars
of derivatives outstanding I mean the
numbers are very large we have a very
large economy with a very very large
financial system I agree with you that
making clear to members of Congress and
to the public what the money is doing is
important I am NOT I don't of course
want to speak for the Federal Reserve I
think in many cases the terms are
disclosed when they've released new when
they have announced new facilities as
they call them to lend to particular
institutions with particular types of
collateral that's like a to come are
rated here aid does anybody know has it
been made public who has received this
2.3 trillion and under what terms is
that a public information I think some
of that is public and some is not so
some of the institutions that have
received help are disclosed but don't
you know they are not but don't you
think it's a little bit weird and a
little bit undemocratic that the
taxpayers of this country are providing
help maybe it's good maybe it's bad
maybe it's right how do you know there
aren't huge conflicts of interest
how do you know you're not giving money
to your friends if we don't know
anything about it you know we argue here
we have to our debates on a 50 million
dollar appropriation you know about
trillions of dollars I don't know maybe
the Chairman does I know if you have
information you don't have information
I mean I think it's it's
incomprehensible but tell me why you
love Danny eat gob see you could ask
members of the FEHB Reserve Board to
come testify to you and to explain what
they've been doing I think one argument
that is worth keeping in mind for not
disclosing everything is concern about
the stability of institutions one of the
reasons why the Federal Reserve's
discount window which stands ready to
lend institutions that announced rate
does not have a lot of stitute that turn
up is because those institutions are
concerned that revealing their borrowing
will cause a run of sorts on the
institution well I do want one advantage
of the fair reserves facility that
didn't reveal who was getting those
kinds of loans is one of the first
things they did was the institution's
would feel free to come without risking
that kind of I do I really do understand
that but on the other hand III think the
average person would think it's
incomprehensible again of course that's
the word we keep using about this whole
financial disaster there trillions of
dollars are being lent out in without it
transplants or accountability are the
meat switchgear take you to a more
mundane subject when we're all for this
huge financial disaster there has been a
criticism of the CBO for a number of
years and I know you have a tough job
you have to assess how much if I
introduce legislation how much is it
going to cost the tax base that's fair
enough the problem that you have is
sometimes legislation is introduced
which will cost a certain amount of
money but it actually will save money
give you an example we're going to
introduce very shortly at legislation to
build a number to greatly expand the
number of community health centers
around this country focus on primary
health care preventative health care a
lot of studies out there suggests that
by keeping people from going into an
emergency room keeping people from going
into a hospital cuts back on Medicaid
cuts back on Medicare expenditures not
to mention expenditures and the whole
health care system that really you save
substantial sums of money so if I
introduce this and the cost goes what it
will cost us is going from 2 billion to
8 billion
for a five-year period how do you assess
I think we can make the case that we're
saving taxpayers money how do you put
that into your equation in analyzing how
much that legislation cost lore saves
our objective is very clearly to include
all of the ramifications of legislation
in that reports to you I was just
meeting for the first time the day
before yesterday
with people at CBO who estimate costs
for s chip heading toward I guess being
just chip and one of the very important
factors they keep track of is how people
move between Medicaid and S chip
depending on the rules and what the
states how the states respond how
private individuals respond we keep
track of people moving from private
insurance looking at how employers
respond if we if we decide to
incorporate all that do you do things
like saying oh if the person go to a
doctor early and not end up with a
terrible illness that we have to spend
$100,000 in the hospital for that's a
saving yes do you guys throw that into
the equation yes that's certainly one of
the one of the ramifications that we're
trying to capture now we don't always
have evidence consistent with the
intuition that we or others know but
where we can find evidence we work very
hard to incorporate as many different
effects and the interconnected world
that we can as we the criticisms the
chairman has been is that's pretty easy
if why bill goes from 2 billion to 8
billion with spending six billion that's
pretty clear but we are also saving
substantial some-somebody and understand
that ha that part of it is a little bit
harder to determine but I hope you give
serious thought and build into your
analysis the savings as well as the
expense we absolutely do everything in
that direction l can good just